die menschen im landkreis münchen
mussten sich am montagabend in
sicherheit bringen gewitter mit starkem
regen und hagelschauern sind vor allem
über den süden und osten deutschlands
gezogen
in bayern gab es nach angaben des
deutschen wetterdienstes dwd dazu
orkanböen und große hagelkörner mit
einem durchmesser von bis zu 6 cm
hagelkörner durchschlugen autoscheiben
und die fans an wohnhäusern binnen
weniger minuten standen mehrere straßen
unter wasser
die anwohner konnten oft nur zusehen und
auch die feuerwehr werfen
in den orten lagen vereinzelt dachziegel
auf der straße
die straßen waren grünen vor lauter
abgerissenen ästen und blättern im
stadtgebiet von münchen wurden mehrere
hundert einsätze gezählt
zwei menschen sollen nach ersten
erkenntnissen leicht durch hagelschlag
verletzt worden sein
das unwetter wirkte sich auch auf den s
bahn verkehr in und um münchen auszüge
wurden zeitweise in bahnhöfen zurück
gehalten an mehreren stellen stürzten
bäume ins live wie groß die entstandenen
schäden sind war am dienstagvormittag
noch unklar
so viel ist klar sie werden erheblich
sein
auch im südwestlichen niedersachsen
musste die feuerwehr nach unwettern
anrücken nach heftigen regenfällen
liefen keller und tiefgaragen voll die
kanalisation konnte das wasser nicht
mehr aufnehmen das wasser stand auf
mehreren straßen bis an die
bordsteinkante und auch darüber
der starke regen prasselte örtlich so
stark nieder dass mehrere autofahrer
freiwillig am straßenrand stoppen und
warteten ist das unwetter vorbei war
wer weiter fuhr kam nur noch langsam
voran und wurde an die überfluteten
straßen nahezu ausgegrenzt wegen des
unwetters wurden bäume entwurzelt die
feuerwehr musste mit kettensägen
anrücken um straßen und wege wieder frei
zu bekommen
am späten montagabend kam es auf der a
29 zu einem schweren unfall
ein autofahrer war während des heftigen
regens ins schleudern geraten und hatte
die kontrolle über sein fahrzeug
verloren er wurde dabei lebensgefährlich
verletzt
die autobahn musste zeitweise voll
gesperrt werden
stark betroffen von den unwettern war
auch sachsen je fielen laut dwd 30 bis
50 liter regen pro stunde
die menschen in berlin und brandenburg
wurden in der nacht zum dienstag von
gewitter donner und blitzen aus dem
schlaf gerissen
medienberichten zufolge wurden über
10.000 blitze gezählt